[Music]
and I want to prove that it's an
everyday I go out and practice all my
shooting like it's game if I can make
some habits and some are Jackson after
the 49 to 13 win on Sunday you made a
point last night that I'd never realize
before that guy has a gigantic neck
right you almost tried to compare him to
Takeo Spikes nobody has a neck like
Takeo Spikes but that's a quarterback
what John Harbaugh between between the
hut coach and the quarterback of the
Ravens those are two of the thickest
next I've seen in football yeah yeah
yeah hardball wins the award of the
coaching but Lamar Jackson I've never
seen a quarterback with a neck like that
and you know that like like can we just
stop talking about the thing he's a
quarterback
let's get over it like so we're gonna
ask him every week like oh hey you keep
winning games you keep going to the
playoffs you keep playing awesome
are you proving you're gonna quarter I
get he's already proving it let's move
on he's awesome now he's proving he's
the MVP in football and I like his
sweater - that's a nice first thing you
know he doesn't he's got good not great
passing numbers but you don't need to
have great passing numbers when you have
that dual threat and you can run but it
doesn't matter at the end of the day
when you see them win football games the
reason they win is cuz Lamar Jackson
makes the three or four best plays on
the field just we're fine let me just go
find his passing numbers were
spectacular but he only threw the ball
17 yeah well get right he doesn't have
to it's not all about the pass with them
because he's got a special you know set
of skills he's got multiple games this
year with a perfect passer rating 150
8.3 multiple games though alright here's
the draft trivia to determine the first
selection in the sunday statement draft
Matthew Stafford was scratched yesterday
ending his streak of 136 consecutive
starts which quarterback has the longest
active streak of consecutive starts oh
now right now oh man active back right
now hold on I got your brain active oh
no it's your brain active right now I'm
gonna make sure I'm ready no
I thought it was like so obvious I don't
know why I didn't do that damn it I said
I was gonna say Philip Rivers and I
chickened out Philip Rivers has 217 he
only needs to start every game for
another five years to tie Brett Favre at
297 I have a feeling that's not going so
alright first pick for me I got to go
with the MVP I got to go with Lamar
Jackson I got to go with that spin move
I got to go with the perfect passer
rating he is the guy that we saw at
Louisville he is the guy he is doing at
the NFL level exactly what he did and
and I doubted he'd be able to do it not
because I thought oh he shouldn't be a
quarterback but I didn't think that that
you know be it's a higher it is your
skills have to step up to the next level
and he dismissed I slashed right your
point well he was heavier yeah I think
he tried to put on the extra little
layer of armor so he could withstand the
NFL pounding and he's found the balance
where he can withstand the pounding and
he also can move like he did relative to
everyone else when he was at Louisville
winning the Heisman Trophy actually had
a better year the following season the
team wasn't as good so he wasn't in
consideration for the Heisman again but
he's that guy yeah MVP they got the
Heisman package too in the backfield did
you notice that yesterday it was RG 3
Lamar Jackson a marking by three husband
winners they call it the husband package
and Griffin got a handoff I expect we're
gonna see that more you know when a team
has a special season like this you start
seeing that creativity they're having
fun they creep in we're gonna see more
RG 3 in that pattern how many teams have
you ever had two Heisman Trophy winners
in their backfield let alone have three
that's kind of crazy I didn't even think
about that well I mean I don't like to
be Captain Obvious but I got to go to
Captain Kirk and the Vikings here I got
to I mean come on the narrative and not
just cuz you and you're wearing the
Jersey I mean this is bigger than you
even though you're a real pain in the
butt with this subject but the Vikings
of course that was a statement I mean
nobody thinks they can win games like
they did last night full team every week
but I'll go Kirk just that Kirk Cousins
okay but either way I mean it was a
thing around the whole team I mean it
was encompassing Mike Zimmer as well but
yes Kirk Cousins especially yes he made
a statement yesterday to go listen you
know I can win games like this on the
road
that was a nice athletic throw there
gives his guy a chance either he catches
and nobody catches it else I'll you know
go off with something Rodney Harris and
said to like if it wasn't like a like a
whoa oh my gosh this is an unbelievable
performance he didn't try to do too much
he took what was there and he made some
big throws in some big moments too when
the football game for the Vikings so
that was a huge statement for him
personally and I think for the Vikings
in general just to go like we weren't
sure now we can go out another kind of
for real in the NFC and they're
dangerous and they can be a pain in the
button to play off and the thing is with
every blown opportunity to change the
narrative there'd be more pressure with
each year missing opportunity and if you
don't end that it only gets worse when
you play Seattle right on a Monday night
it only gets worse if the week 15 Sunday
night game against the Chargers remains
in primetime it only gets worse the
Monday night against the Green Bay
Packers on December 23 so they needed to
break it and especially before the
postseason because and remember Mike
Zimmer told us at the league meetings in
March that they lose in prime time
because you're playing good teams in
prime - of course you know that yeah
otherwise that game would be just a
tough game against a good opponent
doesn't matter whether it's like a likes
out of it yeah exactly
all right next up for me I'm gonna go
Grady Jared two and a half sacks
yesterday for the Atlanta Falcons two
weeks to get ready for the game a team
that everyone had given up on I was
gonna go Dan Quinn but I want to go
specifically with a player but but they
rallied around this embattled coaching
staff they were fired up for the game
they were fired up to face the Saints
this one I've and you know I I wasn't we
both picked the Saints to win straight
up but the Falcons the cover cuz we both
had a feeling livid something was gonna
happen here we didn't quite envision the
upset but we did envision that the
spread was too big given the nature of
this rivalry and I wish I would have I
wish I would have squeezed that feeling
a little bit harder but I still wouldn't
have come to the point
nowhere I would have said the Falcons
are going this game they were late a
horrible all year yeah I mean and a game
like that a game like that actually
makes you say you know it's like when a
kid who's had straight DS finally shows
up with straight A's on the report card
the first thing dad says is where the
hell was this yeah all the other report
cards what are you doing you're capable
of doing it now you've been capable of
doing it later the Falcons are capable
of doing what they did
let's see him do it more off yeah I mean
again it was a shocking you're right I
mean it was just both sides of the ball
Atlanta ran the ball with some success
on the the Saints the Saints defense
couldn't get off the field but I think
the big thing get straight a's in your
life yeah I did yeah I did a very nice
place actually no moment millennial
great impression here at Texas I did
worse from there
of course of course you got the straight
A's I did I did I did shut your mouth so
blaze a tutor who was six foot five with
no more power later on in college thank
you I was getting tutors for sure but
the other thing is to to your point with
the Saints and common opponents like the
Falcons to there are a defense that
plays a lot of people at the line of
scrimmage and I'm just gonna say this I
wonder you know you take away the short
passing game from the Saints I'm just
saying I know I'm not sold to Drew Brees
and the passing game can beat you deep
down the field just like we said at the
end of last year just saying just thrown
it out there okay
Jamal Adams that's why I'm gonna go we
haven't talked about this game in the
Battle of New York and I just got to
give this guy credit first off he was
the best player on the field yesterday
yes he was a game changer
two sacks had a big fourth in one tackle
that stopped the Giants drive but this
sack here was really a game changer I
mean it just took it took him right out
and Hollywood Henderson off of Terry
Bradshaw in Super Bowl 13 yeah and we
kind of went into halftime with like oh
okay the Jets got or got up early and
the Giants kind of battled back at the
end of the first half and you went to
the Giants kind of have control of this
football game they get the ball to start
the second half and then Jamal Adams
blitzes takes it right out of his hands
like you said scores a touchdown this
you know is the best safety in football
in my opinion and I think anybody that
watching football would certainly say
he's one of the two or three best but
for me he is number one call it a fumble
when that happens it's like oh yeah but
a really great job by Jamal Adams yeah
and and look I don't know how many games
the Jets are gonna win the rest of the
way and you got Sam Donald and Jamal
Adams both talking about playoffs and I
love that fire I love that intensity and
I wouldn't expect anything but a belief
that until you're mathematically
eliminated you still have a chance but
it's a game to building
right Anil Jones just to say tune
another four touchdown performance no
interceptions
I mean it's gosh he is he's answered the
critic somewhat but I feel like the
storm clouds are gonna continue to
gather around you got Pat Shermer yeah
his record to Ben McAdoo and John Mara
the Kohinoor the Giants was so upset
yesterday in the locker room he wouldn't
even look at the reporters uh that's not
good for anybody so we're gonna have to
keep an eye on how the rest of the
season unfolds for the stops though
Giants a I'm stalling I know you're
right I'm filibustering here cuz I don't
know who to pick there's a lot of
different ways I can go I gotta go Mike
Tomlin okay look yeah there's only what
happens with coach of the year is that
it's the team entering the season that
had the lowest expectations that are the
most exceeded and that coach becomes the
coach of the year like oh we thought
they were gonna be four and twelve ended
up being ten and six that guy's the
coach of the year rarely do you get
Coach of the Year consideration for how
you deal with adversity that happens
during the year to lose your starting
quarterback week to to be owin three and
I was doing the calculation of hey that
you know this team hasn't had a record
worse than then five wins in 50 years
and they had their work cut out for them
and here they are five and one over the
last six games
it's amazing to bless you it's amazing
to see what they've done bless you again
thank you it's amazing to see what the
Steelers have done and Mike Tomlin is
the guy who steadied the ship Mike
Tomlin is the guy who gets them to
believe in themselves thinking and
week-out and that's why I believed
yesterday they would win the game it
doesn't matter if James Connor plays it
doesn't matter if juju Smith Schuster's
healthy it doesn't matter if Mason
Rudolph makes a mistake it's not none of
that matters know what matters is this
team believes they are that energy is
the sum of the but is it the sum of the
parts greater than the I never know I
don't know either
doors box they open Pandora's box he was
in there anyway I got to get Mike Tom
and credit because he's the guy that is
responsible for what the Steelers are
doing one of the greatest leaders I have
ever been around Mike Tomlin so I'm glad
you're saying that not nobody he's one
of the greatest speakers in front of the
room a bunch of players whatever it may
be my experience around Mike Tomlin his
people skills and motivational skills
are as good
is anybody in football and I will never
back down from that I saw in person when
I was in Tampa and he was a DB coach
special the whole is greater than the
sum of the part thank you very much
Brian Flores it's a second near Mike
Tomlin I'm gonna give him a little love
okay you know oh they're tanking and all
that now they're still fighting down
there in Miami and that's because
they're head coaches of fighter
that's what Brian Flores is you know he
grew up in Brooklyn New York and a
really bad bad section Brownsville right
same area Mike Tyson grew up well his
team plays like that oh yeah we traded
everybody away great we're building for
the future doesn't matter
I mean they've shown here the last few
weeks that they're not just gonna be
like a pushover completely barely lost
the Redskins barely lost the Bills had
the Pittsburgh Steelers on the ropes and
now they've won two in a row which I
just got to give him a lot of credit
that staff coming from New England knew
they wouldn't give up and knew they
would continue to fight in game plan and
you know they're there they're gonna be
a pain in the butt for a lot of teams
here down the stretch all right we're
gonna get you ready for a huge Monday
night game between the San Francisco
49ers buffet so take a look at the draft
because today I'm sorry Chris all due
respect what I whipped your bear wearing
the jersey large Jackson X okay under my
pictures are Kirk Cousins Jamal Adams
and Brian Flores I win you lose that's
okay you used to it by now
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports